hi everyone thank you for joining us
today and a very warm welcome to the
webinar fashionably green this event is
presented by the design singapore
council and the national design center
i'm felicia from the design singapore
council and i will be your mc for today
today's session fashionably green will
explore what sustainable fashion is and
how fashion labels are going green in
innovative ways
our panel of speakers will be sharing
more about themselves and their work in
the first half of the session before we
move into a panel discussion and q a
segment for the second half
and with that it is now my absolute
pleasure to introduce our panel of
speakers for today
we have with us jin lee co-founder and
designer of jin lee studio a
contemporary women's wear label that
prides itself on creating thoughtfully
designed pieces
joining us is also felicia toe founder
of norst a loungewear label that creates
beauty sustainably by working closely
with makers and vulnerable communities
and last but definitely not the least we
have with us from the uk arabella turek
chief operating officer of petit ple a
material technology company that makes
clothes that grow with you
moderating our session for today is
daniel boy creative director and founder
of the front row and singapore's very
own godfather of fashion
so without further ado i'm going to hand
over the time to daniel to officially
kick-start today's session daniel over
to you please
thank you so much felicia hi everyone
welcome to fashionably green um so i'm
daniel boy let me tell you a little bit
about myself now daniel boy bc which
stands for before covet i was a fashion
show runner a fashion curator and a
creative director of fashion festivals
with the front row which was started
during covet we started the front row as
an online portal to support
asian fashion creatives showcase and
highlight sustainable fashion businesses
responsible fashion practices as well as
cruelty free fashion i'm really excited
to be moderating this panel with three
very
interesting and exciting guests i'd like
to introduce them all to you um ladies
as i introduce you i'd like you to
switch on your cameras and give us a
one-liner on what you think sustainable
fashion means to you our first guest is
jin lee from jilly studio hi jen hi
daniel how are you
good tell us
what does sustainable fashion mean to
you
um for me as a designer i believe is
to not produce if it's not needed okay
so i'm not less into you know kind of
investigating the materials though those
are important but for us if we can don't
produce it try not to produce it so
let's waste
fantastic less waste okay our next guest
is felicia to hi felicia
hello
how are you
i'm felicia as well yes
for us
it's about longevity and being
respectful towards people and
environment so our approach to
sustainability is simple and consists of
two parts firstly we think carefully
about who we work with in the making of
our clothing and in our case that's
artisan families and marginalized
communities in asia and secondly we
think about how it's made how clothing
can be made in ways that are gentle on
the planet
fantastic um okay well we'll hear from
you a little later on meanwhile let me
introduce my third guest she's all the
way from london arabella turret hi
arabella
hello good afternoon oh good morning
anyone is joining me
um
uh sustainable passion means identifying
meaningful solutions through
generating
great user dialogue
uh in order to
achieve solutions which really stand the
test of time and meet those longevity
equations
fantastic thank you very much okay we're
going to hear from arabella a little
later on but as you can see sustainable
fashion means different things to
different people but it all ties back to
the fact that we are all trying to be
more responsible fashion practitioners
or consumers
okay according to wikipedia sustainable
fashion which is also known as eco
fashion is a movement and a process of
fostering
change to fashion products and the
fashion system
towards greater ecological integrity and
social justice a sustainable fashion
concerns more than just addressing
fashion textiles or products it
addresses the entire manner in which
clothing is produced who produces it and
how long the lifespan of the product is
before it reaches the landfill now this
sustainable movement combats the large
carbon footprint that the fashion
industry and fast fashion have created
by reducing greenhouse gas emissions
combating air and water pollution and
climate change all right um i'm going to
get the labels to talk about their own
sustainability journeys and why they
made the choices they did a little later
on but first
uh let me introduce them back one by one
to tell us a little bit about each label
let's start off with jin lee
so i'm jin i'm a
designer and the co-founder of genie
studio a women's by label so me and
tamiya my partner we are both designers
so i'm fashion designer and he's an
industrial designer for us as a
um as a fashion label what we do we do a
lot of uh focusing on exploration of a
textile form and fit and as well the
functionality of the clothings
to who we design for so as i mentioned
just now for us being sustainable is
really to kind of like think about what
we do and do it slowly
i think one of the things about
being sustainable as a designer is also
sustainably tuning out design like not
you know speeding up in such a way that
every week is new collection so we kind
of like
try to do what we say slow fashion that
just really slow it down so my strength
and interest lie in the way 2d transform
to treat
walk around a 3d form and that's for me
my personal interest so a lot of fabric
manipulation and also patterning which
really interests me and also in the end
of the day because we work with a body a
user we call so we design around the
user so how do i make it more flattering
for her how does she look in it how does
she feel in it so this is kind of what
we pre ourselves for what we do
and one of the technique that we use
in
fabric manipulation technique was uh
fleeting so hammer plating especially
it's quite a low-tech
kind of method
mainly kind of using contour couture to
kind of texturize the fabric and then
make it into clothes so what we do we
try to play with it so that it becomes
kind of like the way
it kind of applying our
last mile production onto the finished
item okay you'll see a bit more through
the slide and all that so the project
that i wanted to mention is a making
shop we branded it as make so you see
that kind of branding that's called just
make in present tense which is like uh
um that is making while you need it so
basically the whole idea is that we
redesign
well the key point was that we're trying
to address two key issues we're trying
to kind of like tackle two key problems
that we have in our industry the fashion
industry
one of them is assess stock we all know
that okay so i don't have to elaborate
on that and also like that that's kind
of changing customer demand
for
health shopping in a brick and mortar
shop i'm also a retailer so as far as a
fashion
designer we also have a retail shop so
we felt that those two key challenges
was what we want to address in our
solution so when we thought through we
thought like you know what do we what
are we known for what do we have what's
the skills that we have so we kind of
like um
end up with this project that we call
making shop so what we do we basically
redesign everything that we can redesign
okay so we redesigned the way we retail
we redesigned the way we produce the way
we design design and also the way we
kind of like put the whole thing
together so simply we break the
the whole thing up into modules so we
don't produce the whole
item we just do a base and if it's uh
you know the stripe and all that you
know we started with
back and then move on to top and stuff
so a bit smaller object because we are
women's web but it was just like to
allow us to kind of start in a smaller
scale and smaller
pleating size
and uh so basically that that was the
idea was that we want to assemble the
whole thing when people want it when our
customer won it so the when we designed
the product you have to make sense
because what we didn't want was to put a
sewing machine in the place because it
have to be
felt quite designed the process and the
product and both also because um you
know hammer plating is quite
laborious and it's quite prone to
defects and all that but we really like
that we felt that that's also part of
slowing it down and we also have like
make experience recall which is like
basically um i mean we make the bags in
the store but we
kind of like allow the consumer or the
customer to make it for themselves so we
guide them through the process we don't
charge you know for that experience at
all but what we do is that we just guide
them through the process because we
believe also by changing that
relationship you know as the owner of
the product to being the maker of the
product it changes your relationship to
the product and hopefully you will
treasure a bit more a bit longer and
that's how we felt that we can
you know change this
way we consume
consuming too much too fast
and we kind of like call it like
modernizing the craft so we can localize
the production so this whole project is
localized so we are not uh
because of the way it's being built so
we only trigger like uh the more a laser
score the bags are laser-cut and uh
obviously the whole thing was pretty
split in store and we also have to build
the home machinery by ourselves because
we want it to fit into the retail store
environment that was the key so you see
actually in this picture that little
fridge in the end that's the steamer
and yeah so basically that's what we
that's what we do that's our part in it
that's just how can we change around the
way we thought about
retail and obviously how we think about
designing products as well surrounding
the customer experience
okay that's all for me thank you
thank you jin for your sharing let us
now welcome felicia on screen please to
share more about norst felicia over to
you please
hi everyone thank you for being here um
yeah so just to share a little bit more
about norse norse is a sustainable
loungewear and home goods label that
partners with artisan families in asia
i'm a practicing architect and i love to
travel precove it anyway
and nost was born from a couple of
journeys when i was in india i went into
villages with craft communities and met
with heritage artisans who created
fabrics out of their homes that inspired
me to start lost
we designed garments from start to end
and our prints are inspired by
architecture such as the concourse
building
our artisans then print on raw fabrics
using heritage techniques such as block
and buttock printing
making fabrics from scratch gives us the
freedom to decide what goes into each
garment such as the type of dye and the
raw fabric used
designing the supply chain from start to
end became a good springboard to think
about sustainability which essentially
is about holistic cycles designing
something from cradle to cradle
a lot of my understanding around
sustainability was something i learned
from the artisans for example one of the
artisans uses only natural plant-based
dyes for fabric printing
the black in our modular rope was made
with iron bought with pomegranate like
the one you see here on the right
knowing the people who make our clothing
first hand leads to a different way of
thinking about sustainability it makes
you think about the impact of dyes used
on crops because traditionally artisans
wash fabrics in the rivers which are
surrounded by farmland
we think about the makers
who wash and dye the fabrics by hand
would we want to put our own hands into
the dye pot day in and out if we were
them
when thinking about sustainability it is
a big word but what comes to mind for me
is longevity how to sustain a mode of
life in a way that is kind on the planet
so that there is continuity and
longevity of resource
we approach sustainability in two ways
by rethinking who we work with and how
it's made
because for us sustainability is not
just about the environment but also
about the people who make our clothes
we choose to work with small-scale
artisan families who have passed their
skills down to generations
many of them tell us that they find it
difficult to compete with commercial
suppliers because of the time that is
involved in making things by hand
many of their neighbours have given up
the trade with children migrating to
cities in search of that hot work
but we hope to preserve these precious
heritage crafts so that it does not
become obsolete
we also hope to partner more with
marginalized communities in the making
of our products
some of our cushions our dress and mask
collections are ethically produced by
two ngos based in singapore and india
that train and employ women at risk of
trafficking and exploitation
our second approach to sustainability is
about being gentle on the planet by
considering how things are made
so we use natural eco fabrics such as
organic cotton and tencel
which are biodegradable
and also environmentally friendly dyes
our clothing comes packaged in reusable
cotton pouches instead of single-use
plastics
something we are currently working on is
to develop artisanal fabrics made from
pineapple leaf fibers or pelf for short
this project is called pelvcraft and
it's under the good design research
grant
we've partnered with a local company
called next evo which collects pineapple
leaves from thailand and converts them
into yarns that are blended with tencel
and cotton we then take these yarns and
place them in the hands of our artisans
based in indonesia to weave and buttock
print into new sustainable fabrics
it's exciting for us to be able to
bridge old and new to create innovative
eco fabrics with a strong heritage story
southeast asia is a leading producer of
pineapples globally so for every
kilogram of pineapple fruit 2 kg of
leaves are generated
these excess leaves are usually burnt or
landfilled leading to waste generation
and pollution
converting agricultural waste into
usable fabrics is a wonderful
opportunity to close the loop
pineapple fabrics are not new but it is
difficult for artisans to gain access to
the yarns because they are usually
processed in small batch cottage
industries so supply is unstable and
expensive
but with puffcraft we hope to tap on the
commercial technology that makes these
blended yarns possible at scale and put
them in the hands of these heritage
artisans thus nudging them towards the
growing market for eco-textiles and
future proofing their craft
we hope that norse will be known as the
pineapple pajamas brand if this project
goes well
and that artisans will be able to
continue their craft for centuries to
come
thank you
thank you felicia for your sharing last
but not least could we welcome eric bell
to join us on screen please
perfect so i'm aaron
um as my introduction i am ceo of a
particular material technology company
based app of london and we've had quite
a
unique
origin
our founder whose background is an
aeronautical engineer came up with the
uh petite uh
a company which produces primarily
growing clothes for the children uh
because children grow through seven
sizes in their first years on earth
creating an
incredible amounts of waste
um when he gifted an item for his nephew
in denmark by the time it arrived it was
already small indicating that there's a
plethora of problems within children's
world but slicing and officially
leading as engine to
stock surplus and excess um creates a
huge amount of externalities negative
externalities within the fashion
industry which
principally impact the health of the
planet
but also it signaled for the user that
there was a poor intelligence with
respect to sizing and and also
unique sizing between brands
so with all these problems and these
data signal points uh he decided to use
and apply his insights from aeronautical
engineering
into
satellite animals to create a texas
which could grow bi-directionally and
expand
all over the world which is really
really exciting especially for
a company which is something uh
which has sustainability to its core and
it's about the bedrock and communication
is so important administration budget uh
within the makerspace uh so much about
uh the success of your process
and project
relies on communication
verbal uh not
only physical um as is really important
at the design stage of the physical
product
with the success
of the children's world uh soon after
launching uh pcp has
launched um
and also uh moss which is really
exciting and we've got more avenues uh
coming in to our heads
and uh we've
identified all solutions through
retaining really great dialogue between
our user communities through instagram
through emails and even when we launched
uh
because of such viral engagement uh we
created early on a really great uh email
community so when we were ready to test
products
our community uh were able to uh test it
and
purchase comments uh which were
pre-commercial uh viability uh
privately and it sold out within 24
hours which is really really exciting um
but as mentioned earlier a real poor
part of our ethos is
designing uh
projects and uh designing ideas and
statement pieces which they are able to
really live in the world of a real human
user and because of our approach
i think we have been very successful
in not only translating our medium
online but also within physical spaces
so
on account of your approach in the
origin we're currently in the national
science center waste refinery exhibition
but we've also been featured in exhibits
in
the art institute of chicago the
philadelphia museum of modern art um the
science museum in london we've got a pun
exhibition at the victoria albert museum
of childhood owning in 2023 and
i think
within the sustainable fashion space
there's such an opportunity to
uh think differently and act differently
uh in a way that
can combine insights from all
disciplines it's not a problem just for
fashion designers to fix i think there's
a lot of playing on uh fashion schools
uh because
uh there has been a preservation of a
particular type of model but
for example in biology which is my
background uh i study uh neuroscience at
undergrad and i'm a firm conservationist
there's always this idea of what is
correct balance of preservation versus
conservation and i think that goes
everything from
that can be uh transported to this uh
communication
uh today regarding fashion which should
be preserved from
all techniques and all styles of
learning and what should we consider
from the sustainable fashion startups
uh you are pioneering
thank you
thank you very much arabella and to
felicia and jin as well can i get all of
you to switch on your
cameras so that we can plunge straight
into this very exciting discussion
i'm going to
start by talking about the business
of
sustainable fashion all right taking
that first step towards operating a
sustainable business now all of you have
talked about why why you started or why
you decided to
to go down the sustainability route but
um i think a lot of people are very
interested to know how you started it
you know the problems that you had
looking for
the r d material costs and all that so
do you want to um have a little chat
about
taking that first step towards operating
a sustainable business let's start with
jin
um i think we we started at a we are a
women's wear label before anything so i
mean at that point we never thought that
we are not sustainable anyway it's
always about being slow about being
independent label so i think this uh
being sustainable this uh
word itself is quite i think is quite
key over the last
few years as we
as review it but for us i think one of
the things that what we do what we try
to do like the project i explain is kind
of like trying to localize where we can
and try to reduce where we can but i
think one of the key challenges that we
had was changing mindset
changing my set of suppliers
changing mindset of our staff changing
my set of uh everything that has to do
with uh you know this whole system that
is built on quantity on speed to market
you know even discount you know it's
very i think it's mindset change was the
toughest that we had to under and the
goal but beside that the business was
there so it was just a lot to fix in
terms of mindsets like
sure felicia what about you um you know
you've got a really interesting story
about your travels and
and and all that
was it difficult in taking that first
step to start a sustainable business
yeah so um because of my training in
architecture and also um not in fashion
per se
i think it led me to approach fashion
with a very different lens
um yeah and
my journey really started with the
artisans and that's where also i drew a
lot of lessons on sustainability because
they've been practicing this crafts for
centuries in ways that um
are very very sustainable yeah so um one
of the benefits of being able to work
with artisans is also that they produce
in small batches
yeah so i think like jin mentioned
earlier one of the
big problems in fashion is the
generation of waste from excess stock
yeah so being able to work with
suppliers that are smaller scale and
more nimble with lower order quantities
definitely helped in terms of piecing
together a supply chain that makes a lot
more sense for the environment
yeah and also i think because the
business model that we kind of landed on
was had to do with creating fabric from
scratch rather than purchasing off say a
supplier or mail
so that allows us to be very flexible in
terms of specifying what exactly goes
into it so for example we are able to
specify the raw material the organic
cotton or tencel
and also the type of dyes that are used
like they could be natural plant-based
or
low-impact azo free dyes
yeah and um
so
because it's kind of
happening in a really small scale and
and
quite intimate that gave us actually a
very interesting way to go about
sustainability from a small business
approach
arabella what about you
us we had an administration presentation
called uni
as a student project basically gained
incredible attention however the
intention of the project was always to
live in the real world so as soon as our
founder
uh exhibited the design and shortly
after the award he
and that's pretty impossible to do
without money and also pretty reckless
from a commercial
always uh moreheads
do you think being in different parts of
the world has uh has influenced the way
you've you've decided to approach this
uh
the way you run your business and the
direction of your business for example
felicia you mentioned that being in this
part of the world and working with the
artisans and all that if you had been
based in the west would your business
model have been different
yeah that's a good question i think
definitely we are influenced by our
context
and it also directly links to the kind
of networks and access that we have
um yeah so i think
for example now that i'm working on
puffcraft the pineapple textile project
right you realize that southeast asia is
for example
one of the world's global producers of
pineapples yeah and um yeah there is
another competitor brand that's also
producing pineapple leaf textiles yeah
but i think the benefit of being based
here in southeast asia is that we can
keep our
eco footprint actually pretty small and
tight within the region
yeah so in terms of the processing in
terms of the raw materials like where
the leaves are harvested from in
thailand um to the processing and then
shipping it to indonesia the
kind of root that the journey that the
materials need to go on it's a lot
shorter and that
is definitely has benefits for the
environment yeah so it's my taste
one thing i find really interesting is
all of you have such diverse backgrounds
that are not rooted in fashion do you
think that having such diverse
backgrounds has actually helped your
journey and and helped you with r d
let's start with um okay let's start
with arabella
okay
do you think uh having for example a
masters in science and technology has
actually helped you
um with your research and development
and and um
and crafting the direction and the
aesthetic of your brand
so i think with respect to the masters
that i did in
one of the
courses was actually on
the political economy of
science and r d
so when we were starting out
a little bit of knowledge uh
and that lens from a macro perspective
it was really helpful when i was writing
applications for grants
so ptp has won a lot of funding so in
that sense um
that's really helpful uh for design
because that's giving the economic base
and then from um
the whole team is really diverse as well
so
no meeting
um is exited with uh the original idea
which is the
point
um which is great so we're always
challenging each other and growing which
is good friction these two uh positive
discussions let's talk about material
cost next okay um specifically with um
someone like felicia because you're
working directly with the producers uh
you know how do you handle things like
like to bring the cost down of the
pineapple fabrics do you think that
having more
more competitors in the market will help
bring the cost down because there's more
demand for it and also stuff like
packaging you know um
felicia you talked about packaging as
well
uh what about gin and arabella you know
how how do you bring down your
uh how do you how do you be sustainable
in your packaging and how do you reduce
your carbon footprint in
uh when you're when you're shipping you
know you're all shipped overseas so uh
were these questions that that uh that
you had to take into consideration when
you decided to
to start a sustainable business
uh okay let's start with felicia
so
yeah i think mentioned earlier about the
packaging the idea that we try to reduce
single-use plastics when possible so our
clothing comes in reusable pouches
yeah i think on the the question about
material costs um
i think being a fashion newbie helped
because you know
there's this kind of like bravery in
being naive um yeah and
i think also being a small business um
means that
a lot of the costs that fashion brand a
multi-label may traditionally spend on
other items such as marketing
or having a large staff count and
overheads
those are the ways in which we shift
costs away
from the operating of a business and
into
spending on things that actually matter
for us and that would be the quality of
the materials yeah because what we hope
to do is to create timeless pieces made
with good quality and they are like
heirlooms that you can wear again and
again and you can even pass it down so
um yeah for us i think that um
we try to focus on what's
most important or central to the brand
and invest the costs in the area
jin what about you uh you know you you
mentioned that
what you're doing now is actually an
extension of your women's square
business already but when you decided to
go sustainable it wasn't just about um
made in store but it was also about
packaging and reducing the carbon
footprint and all that how did you
address that
um i would maybe speak about the course
first because i find that quite
interesting when we tried to do making
shop everything went up all the costs
went up
but i felt that was a lot of area that
um
that perhaps the cost went down like for
example all the reduction of price in
the end of the season or the storing
away things that are not sold so those
are things are you know like invisible
price invisible cost that we don't have
to into account so sometimes i find that
it's a kind of interesting way to look
at it like um
sometimes it's just
a little bit less but you gain more you
know so i try we try not to look at it
just on the p l you know just numeric
again
and until packaging is the same we asked
the same question what do we want from
this if it means that if we ship
something in the paper packaging and
things get soy is it better or worse but
what we do try to do is like where we
cannot eliminate plastic we try to reuse
or recycle so i think just to i mean we
use the
the poly bag that contains the clothes
like to that like use it for storing use
it for this i mean like we don't invest
in nice boxes in the studio it's always
like a mixed shape of
all the packing material that we got and
because it's nice when you get that kind
of cohesive look but at the same time i
felt like why would i buy more plastic
cup you know if i have this so maybe try
to use that so it's always balancing you
know there's no one
equation or this is what we use or not
just you know what it makes sense for us
that's great you're looking actually at
the big picture which is what i think
everyone needs to do as well arabella
what are your thoughts on this
um so for us because our
user
is never
child is never going to buy our products
online
uh we thought that the packaging uh
was a really unique opportunity to
educate and gamify
the
sustainability
experience and provide a positive
instance
of
great resources so
we actually and also
on the adult user side a lot
they can be
origami folded into a jet pack for the
kids to
zoom around in
some instructions on the other side
and that positive
signal impromptu
is our
way of gamifying the experience of um
and also celebrating uh the fact that
we're sending our items in zero waste
recycle um
but
also prompting them to think about
everything in their life as a potential
game
i think that's really really interesting
okay i'm gonna fast forward um no pun
intended you can't talk about uh
sustainability in fashion without
talking about fast fashion
and slow fashion now fast fashion
obviously has uh tremendous negative
effects on the environment it's uh
highly unethical in terms of production
in order to keep up with the changing
fashion trends the clothes are produced
in numerous quantities
most of the clothes are made of
synthetic fibers as opposed to natural
fibers which means they're made using
earth fossil fuels all right
now 60 of our clothes are made that way
and people spend a lot of these clothes
and because they're so cheap people buy
and throw
how do you uh okay i'm gonna tie this
back to one of the questions that are
coming in uh for the rest of you who
have questions please do send us your
questions and we'll try and answer them
as much as possible
okay i'm gonna tie this back to one
question which someone has sent in so
many gen z's and millennials are
advocating for sustainable fashion but
they are still purchasing from fast
fashion companies what do you think is
the biggest deterring factor for them
and why
so um i'm going to ask this in two forms
one what are your thoughts on fast
fashion and how do you
deter people from um moving away to move
people away from fast fashion towards a
slow fashion model
okay let's start with arabella
so i think
communicating to anyone who isn't
interested in you let's just take a
person to person basis is
quite hard
so um i think
with that instance taking the mood of
evangelizing to those who are interested
in you and building those communities
organically
is the best methods
because uh
i learned very early on in life there
are lots of things you can teach but one
thing you can't teach is motivation
so
if that is um
by growing your own community that will
motivate other people to be interested
in you because by
human nature
we learn from others
they're about the best means so
all right um felicia i want to ask you
about slow fashion
and um
and the idea of uh
perhaps the versatility of clothes for
example um looking at uh the stuff that
you have
i think
you you can't define clothes by genres
anymore because people want to buy
things that that can they can use for
many different uh purposes and i think
covet has has accelerated that
that versatility as well what are your
thoughts on slow fashion
yeah so
the loungewear pieces that we create at
north um i term them versatile to
malware the idea being that we're trying
to expand the range of loungewear beyond
the home to a full mile radius around
your house so you know it's loungewear
that you wouldn't be afraid to answer
the door in or you know pick up like the
phone or do a zoom call-in and even you
know run out to run errands and
wearing it right so this idea of
versatility um and especially so since
cobit where our
boundaries have become so much more
fluid and blurred
between the different modes that we have
for living for working for socializing
things like that
it's all happening within the space of
the home
yeah so
i think that's our approach towards
creating pieces that are versatile and
timeless and also very comfortable
because i think if pieces are
comfortable then you would be more
inclined to reach out for it more and
more
yeah rather than something which is
trendy and would easily go out of style
after a couple of seasons yeah okay all
right i'm gonna pick up on the word
trendy and out of style and i'm gonna
address this question to jin because i
think one of the
one of the appeals of fast fashion is
the fact that they are very
spot on
in pushing trends out but trends come
and trends go
how do you
how do you address that that issue with
people who want new designs all the time
and how do to convert them to
to buying more classic items
i can't convert them i think in the end
it's i have
i try to have uh designs that are more
thought through
but usually we kind of like try to think
about it this way every piece that we
tune out we try to say that does this
look good on just a rack no marketing
around it how does that look how does it
look on the body and you know if it's
can it be like museum worthy like
gallery worthy like how does it look so
you kind of like try to put it in
different state different places and see
like if this piece can sustain kind of
like scrutiny and see how does it feel
so i think that's kind of like more our
design approach and obviously because
the user is a big part of like our
we center all the work around the user
does it feel comfortable can she move in
it and also trying to go through her day
and say that can she wear this casually
can she can she dress it up
and
also like part of the part of the
project with the making shop we're
really trying to reduce the number of
skew that we stock so using the pleats
to play on this
plate on um for example these two these
two size i don't know if you can see me
because my screen is blocking it it's
actually because one square and one
rectangle but it's actually the same
base size but it's just really playing
with the illusion of fleets so i think
for us it's really kind of like
trying to use design really and try to
design
a new look so less trend but just unique
pieces that people
wow okay i like it you know so it can't
pull them away from oh is that trendy
it's not we just design pieces
right okay now um i'm
oh sorry i'm going to talk about um
garmin use and lifespan because that is
a very important part of being
sustainable as well
okay two concepts making a product last
as opposed to making a long
lasting product all right and there are
very subtle differences in that um i
want to push this out to all three of
you and to find out what your thoughts
are on
making a product last versus making a
long lasting product uh
okay let's start with arabella
so i think that us
making a long product is uh
because
uh it's so
contingent uh which is why we did so
much testing but it's also climate
contingent uh which is why when we
started
[Music]
a durable um it could be within the use
life uh from uh
perspective abortion and then uh with
respect to can the design a long lasting
design
[Music]
um
all right um great
gin what are your thoughts on this
making a product last versus making a
long-lasting product
i don't know as usual probably
both it's equally important in both of
them and what we do try to do is uh
savage the clues like sometimes people
come to us say we are in the pleats
by mistake can we replicate you know
like uh just make it last as long as you
you can because i do feel like that is
that kind of emotional attached to
clothing that i i personally am that
kind of person i get emotionally
attached to things and
so i don't own a lot of things because i
get to get attached to them so i'm kind
of like weird that i'm a producer of
goods and but i think i do believe in
having less and treasury a bit more so
we kind of like try to help the customer
to keep it as long as they can so if
things that we can fix replete and you
know we usually take it in sometimes
even brands that knocks ours just so
that we should get to keep it like uh
but i think for me it's a mix of both i
would say
all right okay hold that thought about
hoarding uh once i go on to felicia
felicia i want to ask you about this
this thing which um
i read about
your label uh the cradle to cradle
concept can you tell us a little bit
more about that and tie that also to
traceability because i think that's
that's something that's really
interesting
um yeah so this idea of cradle to cradle
and
that when we design for the lifespan of
a product um we hope that there is a
certain
um
way that we consider the impact of of
something um so when you mentioned
earlier about how do you make a product
last versus making a long-lasting
product what came to mind is that
um
firstly in terms of making a product
last um when there are changes in for
example in your body size or um
as your body changes over time with
being human we come up with collections
where the waistbands are kind of
adjustable
um
the pens and dresses all come with
adjustable waistband so this is
something that gives you a little bit
more
room
to accommodate that
and
versus making a long-lasting product um
i think that speaks about something that
is timeless that can be worn again and
again
um something which is seasonless
um and
but at the same time not too long
lasting because for example if you use
polyester it takes thousands of years to
biodegrade versus
the use of materials like organic cotton
and pencil which would be able to
to last a lifespan of its use but be
able to biodegrade degrade the end of
the day
yeah so i think when you mentioned um
cradle to cradle that really came into
play especially when we were researching
um pineapple textiles
um yeah because
why pineapples right um
yeah i i'm not sure if i mentioned a
little bit earlier about how
um
pineapples are already created right now
there's tons of agricultural byproduct
but um
by taking the waste that is generated
that is normally going to lead to air
pollution when it's burnt and landfilled
and converting it into something which
is usable i think it speaks to this
process of taking waste and converting
into something usable and therefore
taking yeah part of the continuity of
resource that we mentioned
okay now um you talked about
traceability as well can you can you
touch on that very briefly
um yeah so because right now we are
designing the whole supply chain where
the leaves are from farm to fiber to
fabric so at each of these key stages
they take place in a different location
with different suppliers and makers
so our aim is really to at the end of
the day have a qr code attached to the
garment
so as a customer you will be able to
very easily scan it and tell where the
suppliers are based and even have
pictures of the people who made your
codes right so i think that um yeah
increasingly this idea of traceability
is very important
great okay now um hang on to that
thought because i have a question that
just came in which i'm gonna ask in a
short while but um i'm gonna jump in
here first and talk about seasonless
fashion which um
jyn has mentioned and all of you have
seasonless fashion models as well as the
circular fashion economy because i think
those are very very important
buzzwords right now
uh
why did you decide to go seasonless and
um was it a conscious effort and do you
think that that has helped your business
um i'm going to start with jin because
uh you you brought this up earlier uh
you know
i think of course because i mean like
the brand the brand started about a
decade ago so without telling you some
background story but it started over in
israel and uh in israel that's more kind
of like um
a bit more a lot more than singapore but
not so extreme between the seasons so
that was a need to change over a season
the minute it hits like winter or like
in summer so the season change over
quite quickly in singapore less but also
because like when we choose to design
something that is a little bit easier to
transit so layering rather than working
with heavier coats all that stuff it was
a lot easier for inventory and all that
but
so i think it kind of like uh became
our products that we design eventually
so we don't do heavily with like coat
and jacket but work mainly with like
separate things that are easy more
easily layered it is obviously quite
easier to be a bit more sustainable
because you don't have to cut off the
selling date but it's not
i don't think it's uh so much that every
country can do it because you have that
change of weather in the end of the day
the clothing are providing the
protection to our climate in singapore
we might not view it but i think it is
another way to look at it
all right okay arabella you have um a
very unique
uh
approach to uh
not just being seasonless but also
circular because your clothes can last
you through many different sizes and now
you're doing adult wear as well
do you
do you think that has helped you uh
become even more sustainable and what
are your plans for the future in
in uh encouraging people to buy more
pieces because if someone can use a
piece for seven years for instance how
do you encourage how do you build a
business to encourage people to keep
buying while uh
what's maintaining the
the the responsible fashion ethos that
your company has embraced
yeah um
however um
um
these questions uh which i think is also
sometimes forgotten when sustainability
uh businesses
so um
potentially non-compete markets they
were
looking at a few uh something which was
um
and i think
on account of
the low price point because we have lots
of lots of uh
fans who necessarily don't have children
[Music]
so
just because that necessarily
and um felicia you know um with the kind
of product you know earlier we talked
about the versatility of the clothes and
all that
with all three of you do you think that
with every season coming out with
products that match the previous season
so you build on your wardrobe rather
than
than building seasonal items
if you if you uh with your design ethos
of
designing classic items that match
every single item in in your shop it
would encourage people to continue
shopping at gin lee and building up the
wardrobe without having to buy um
frivolous seasonal pieces
do you think that that is uh something
that will help your business
i i'm not catering to all different
uh aspects of her of her lifestyle so
there's things that i don't do i don't
do a um right right a lot of like basic
tea etc so obviously
she's still shopping for other places
but what we get a lot is like with the
statement pieces they always just come
back for like more colors or like
shorter like longer lengths so we got
quite a lot of that kind of repeat
customer
and um
yeah so i i think in the end of the day
like we do like
we we focus our work on
the unique pieces the signature pieces
that makes it different for the customer
that can work from night day to night
more than you know her
total lifestyle because we can't do
everything we are small we're a small
bread right
but you know um i think it it's a great
business model because then you build up
your following and every season they
come to buy new things that they can
match with in previous seasons yeah yeah
they do that yeah yeah okay felicia i'm
very very
interested in in
your development of the pineapple
fabrics but um in relation to um
something which is very close to my
heart it's called cruelty free fashion
because you can't talk about responsible
fashion without
addressing the issue of cruelty-free
fashion and beauty you know against
animal testing and not using animal
products you know a lot of companies are
developing new materials like
leather made from great skins and orange
skins which means you can actually grow
your leather in a lab
there are also
organizations for example london fashion
week has banned
fur on their runway let's see um yes
they're banned um
designers from using animal fur on the
catwalks and then there are pledges by
brands like burberry
gucci and versace to go fur free
and in the same vein there are companies
like adidas and g-star raw which are
doing what uh felicia is doing they are
developing apparel made from
um
waste materials for example ocean
plastics you know um
do you think that this
i want i want to hear your thoughts on
this you know not just
not just on recycling waste but um
the eventual moving away from uh perhaps
animal byproducts
what what are your thoughts of that uh
let's start with felicia
yeah i do see cruelty free fashion as a
trend that's set to continue in the grow
um i think not just in the sphere of
fashion but also in terms of food and
diets a lot of people are turning
towards vegan diets right yeah for us i
think it's it's still nascent but we do
have a couple of homeware products that
use pea silk
so this is a type of silk where
the silkworms are not harmed when they
are harvested when cocoons are harvested
yeah and it's a fairly
new material that actually can be found
in indonesia
and we do see some customers
willing to pay the markup for a material
that's kind of rare because
it's cruelty free
yeah and on the note of um
a lot of interesting materials coming up
right now like mushroom leather and
pineapple leather as well yeah so if
possible it would be a very exciting
direction to pursue to see how to
explore alternatives
arabella any thoughts on on
on this
and you see yourself
branching into r d and using more
unusual fabrics and
for your collections
so on the topic of cruelty free i think
uh
a lot of those brands you just mentioned
i think less than one percent of their
products
so
the fact that they switched to
going cruelty free
i think is more emblematic of another
marketing campaign that's it
um so
i think the subject
of cruelty free versus uh raw innovation
i think
uh is
the last of it is more interesting
especially when
however there are countries which uh
spain that
have uh really rely
on the
use of
for example uh
uh
uh which have maybe been around
millennium
that's great okay i'm going to um ask
one of the questions that someone has um
posted
okay and this is related to rnd
you know all of you have some form of r
d either it's in the way the clothes
grow or in the fabrics and all that and
um this can actually push
costs up now how do you foresee
scalability as an issue given the
additional considerations like cost
process complexity that have to be
factored into sustainable design
let's start with uh
let's start with felicia
yeah i think um scalability is a
is
a good problem but something that
all businesses have to grapple with
whether or not sustainability is part of
the conversation right um
yeah and
i think the benefits of scalability or
scaling up is of course the reduction in
costs and um the increase in in revenue
or the pool
and in our case that would be something
good because we hope to be able to
preserve heritage craft and being able
to grow the market for the artisans on a
global scale would definitely be
something that
would be a plus
yeah i think complexity naturally comes
into play um with the scaling of any
type of endeavor or business
yeah and um
[Music]
possibly then it's a matter of working
out the process in terms of the supply
chain and having checks and balances
to to
see that see how scalability can be
managed
at the right rhythm and pace
jude what about you you mentioned
earlier that with with this whole
movement it's actually become more
extensive so how do you
how do you balance this
um
first of all r this is expensive and
customer might not want to pay for it i
think it's the same question that you
ask about gen z like uh yes that is due
by fast fashion or
i felt like um
r d is expensive and sometimes people
don't understand you know why it's close
not cheap or because there is a
development that goes into it so
you know on the other hand you know if
you want it to be more if you want the
younger generation to buy
perhaps brand that are slower or more
sustainable you know they might not want
to pay the price or can pay the price so
therefore fast fashion seems like an
easy option and for we know like for
fast fashion it's kind of like a lot of
ripping off so you don't have to do the
r d it's a lot quicker you take it you
produce it how it goes you know so
it really reduced the cost on production
and obviously choosing cheaper
material etc so for me i don't have a
clear kind of like um what's the outcome
of it but uh you know as our brand stand
for that we're just going to continue
doing it so even it's going to cost me
more but this is what we do i mean we're
designers we're not like
meant to scale in such a
quantity because then that would be you
know perhaps a very different business
model and that's not us therefore the
price is higher but we are working on
the smaller and slower growth i guess
like
all right arabella what about you um
you've got a very unique uh
concept where clothes grow with you
and um how do you balance that that
balancing the
the idea of
increased r d cost and
an scalability between business model is
really cool uh to our
business um
so um
recently uh
[Music]
um
great okay um okay the next two
questions um i'm gonna combine both
questions because they're kind of
related and they're also related to the
previous question which i asked
the first question is how do you combat
consumer mentality that sustainability
means a more expensive product
and two
do you feel that sustainable or ethical
brands only attract a very niche market
all right uh and do you consider this a
pro and con
okay felicia what are your thoughts on
this
i think speaking as a consumer or a
shopper myself
um one way that i think about it is
as cost per wear rather than as absolute
cost of the product
a little bit something that i
um when i purchase i believe i would
wear at least 30 times
and it's well made it's good quality i
don't see it going out of style or trend
then if i were to do the sums and wear
it over the 30 west the cost per wear
would actually be lower compared to
something which
is trendy
but one just a few times and then
disposed or discarded
so i think that that could be one way to
kind of reframe how we
choose to shop
yeah
and um do you do you only attract a
niche market or do you
see more and more
people embracing your brand
yeah i think um it depends on the markup
that people are prepared to pay for
sustainable clothing and items and that
varies from person to person
um i think at north we try to when we're
not in the luxury market range so we try
to keep it as affordable as as possible
so that that would help to hopefully
encourage more people to try out um a
piece of clothing that's sustainably
made
with
natural materials
and
hopefully you know to get more people
into that trend when they try it for
themselves and actually like it
great jane what about you what are your
thoughts on on
combating the consumer mentality that um
it's a more expensive product
i think we got used to clothes being
cheap i think that's my point of view
yeah you know for me is to
perhaps reverse that a little bit and uh
you know i i i'm not that old but i
remember my grandma can meet or you know
my mom can sew but i don't know if
people have that now so i think for us
because like more on the school of
trying to get that back bring the craft
like what felicia was saying like bring
the craft back so when people are more
exposed to it you can't know how things
are being made
and that changes your relationship with
it you you know and
the value of things changes
when you someone out there make my
clothes and i don't know nothing about
it like if just i got used to that price
i think that's my point of view
all right for arabella your clothes are
quite niche in the sense that
it was meant for children that grow and
then now that you're you're starting to
do adult wear do you think that um
that's a niche market for you or um are
you reaching out to people who may not
have children but what interested in
your clothes as well and how do you
address that issue
yeah yeah so um on account of it the
project going viral we've got uh
so uh
a huge amount of users were able to
support us because there's a lot of
ambassadorship uh from that they
wouldn't want uh the same thing
huge proportions then there are a lot of
people who want to uh
[Music]
okay uh now this this is also kind of
related to that question
uh someone wants to know do you think
that in the future more will go into
thrifting reforming or reworking clothes
buying secondhand and more sustainable
clothes and why i'm going to throw this
open to all three of you anyone want to
take this
um i think
um
[Music]
what
is
[Music]
great okay i'm going to address the next
question to our two um singaporean
ladies because there is a
there's a kind of a mindset i'm not sure
if it still exists that uh vin that
people do not want to buy secondhand
clothes or vintage clothes do you see
that mindset still existing or do you
think it's changed and has it affected
um
the secondhand market or
upcycling for instance um anyone
yeah i can go first i i said when i was
a student i really enjoy it like you go
to you you go to trisha and you look for
like crazy and all that like it's really
really exciting and it's also like how
you what you're going to do to it so
that's that whole like i'm going to
customize it and all that stuff so i
really enjoy it and i think in asia
culture we have a thing about not owning
people's stuff like his second hand is
not firsthand i don't i don't feel that
it's changing like i mean like thrifting
is such a word now you see like you know
our younger colleagues are coming in
with like secondhand stuff and taking
pride and i don't think it's a good
thing
i think if anything it makes them think
about being in an individual rather than
you know or what is that
what is that trend and all that and for
those um i like i personally think that
you know fashion
allowed you to be who you are and you
should you know
so yeah i think it's good it's changing
all right felicia what are your thoughts
on this
yeah i agree i think that the market um
is kind of split there there are still
people significant groups of people that
whenever you say it's something recycled
and then some funny things come and come
and get here you know like oh my
goodness come from where
they've been used before um but at the
same time we do see this trend where
we're not just clothing but there's this
whole shared economy where people are
open to not just sharing your grant
rights or taxi rides but also sharing
your homes your co-working co-living
types of environment and
increasingly we also see a lot of
fashion rental companies that are doing
pretty well um
younger
ladies and men are not averse to
sharing items
thrifting as well as buying secondhand
so i do see that
as a change on the horizon increasingly
so
all right okay i'm going to combine our
next two questions they're really really
good questions and they are
they are applicable to all three of you
so i'd like to hear from all three of
you
one of the questions is
how do you worry about consumers being
affected by sustainability fatigue with
so many brands now claiming to be
sustainable
and related to that what is your opinion
on green washing with companies because
you know as with all
trendy things all companies want to jump
on the bandwagon you know earlier we
talked about
companies uh
that are
that are moving away from uh
from uh animal products
you know but uh they are actually green
washing because it only makes up a small
percentage of their their businesses so
how do you address this you know um i'm
i'm asking all three of you how do you
address the sustainably fatigue
now that
you are joined by so many other people
that claim to be sustainable and
what is your advice to people
who
want to be able to tell the difference
between a company that's green washing
and a company that's genuine
let's go back to you felicia let's start
with you
okay
um
yeah i think we we do see many fast
fashion brands also offering green
products now
while it may be a step in the right
direction there are also a lot of
controvering factors such as
um if you are producing like 52
collections a year the amount of waste
that's being generated
and then you weigh that against having a
couple of items that are made of organic
corn i think
customers are becoming more and more
discerning
about whether or not the brand is green
washing and making purchasing choices
based on that
yeah so i mean it's a good point about
sustainability fatigue
i think that as more and more brands
jump on the sustainably bandwagon what
becomes very critical is the idea of
authenticity or proof
um
yeah and and that requires a certain
level of transparency um to for brands
to be able to be open about
where they're producing who's who's
producing it for them um and tracing
down to their uh all the different
suppliers involved in the supply chain
and so i think transparency increasingly
will become a main feature of brands who
seek to be sustainable because customers
will want to be accountable yeah
okay
and jin what is your opinion on this
i think very soon
[Music]
we're not using the word being
sustainable but i think it's just every
branch should be in a way so i don't i
think it's a
i don't know i feel like uh like i said
i never thought like we are or
you know i felt like it's uh
um
i i feel like it's just slowing it down
for for us it's really slowing it down
because i think the speed of growth like
i say clothes are not meant to be so
cheap but you know because in order to
drive growth everything was produced
in bulk in order to drive down the price
and we know that moq is high the minimum
quantity of order is high because they
want to keep the price low and i can't
if i don't want to produce that quantity
i have to pay a premium so i pay the
premium and that's the the business
model that we choose so i think for us
it's uh we never thought about that we
are in or out i just think that this is
what we do at the end of the day and i
do think that you know whether green
washing or not it's good because it got
a lot of people aware and i think we
have one planet so what is new green
washing i just got a lot of people aware
and i think in the end of the day the
shopper is what control it so if more
people that are well more people ask the
question i think every company i can't
say i'm sustainable because how can
anyone claim that it's just impossible
because what we can try to do is just do
our best effort because it's all the
same plan that we're talking about right
like
yeah i think that's great and i'm hoping
that eventually the word sustainability
will be
not the exception but it's it's going to
be the norm i do want to i do want to
say it's just one last thing i feel like
there should be more regulation because
sometimes even for us when we try to
purchase a raw material and all that you
know well that's recycled but you know
it's very very difficult to get some
kind of like body to look after you know
this kind of thing
because you know you really anyone can
tell you anything and say what it is you
know especially when you start to source
from overseas and all that so i feel
like that regulation is a bit harder for
me and you know you ask for the
certificate and you get some kind of
certificate okay great you know so you
know in the end that you do have to end
up finding um
um you know that's not
a lot of supplies out there that smaller
brand can touch on so that's the key
point you know so if you have a more
established raw material brand usually
they want to sell still at a bigger
quantity i see okay now we've got so
many questions and not enough time so
i'm gonna try and combine all these
questions and and do a speed round very
very very very quickly you talked about
supply okay um one of the questions
which i think is very relevant is um
your key suppliers and all the workers
that are that are at the bottom of the
food chain uh how do you check that they
receive fair living wages and how do you
ensure this
um
okay i'm gonna direct this to felicia
because you work directly with with um
and and more so with these uh very very
quickly how do you how do you check this
um yeah so for us we make it a point to
visit our makers first hand
yeah and uh to
build a relationship with them um and so
we just asked them directly how much do
you pay your worker
and then obviously some of them are more
comfortable sharing some or not yeah but
they would tell us like okay i'm paying
minimum wage i'm paying x amount um and
i guess that's that's how we try to
verify yeah
by
through the relationships that we have
with them and through a process of just
integrity
yeah
great okay this question is specifically
directed at you felicia again it's a
speed round so very very quickly i'm
gonna try and squeeze in as many
questions as possible what is the
comfort level of pineapple fabric or
plastic waste derived fabric compared to
our usual fabrics that our skins are
used to
now that's a great question because
pineapples naturally um there is
a certain kind of spikiness which is why
uh we have to do this research into
developing it for lightweight apparel
use um yeah so
the thing is with nyx evo the
pineapple yarns that we are using are
not 100 pineapple we moderate that by
blending it with other materials such as
tencel as well as cotton so in terms of
hand feel and like against the skin it's
a bit more similar to linen than it is
to cotton
yeah and because the fibers are very
strong and it's like breathable so i
guess linen is the scratchiness of linen
is a bit of a good mental picture
fabulous okay last two questions very
very quickly now this question um
is directed to the
artistic and designer in all three of
you okay how do you maintain design
innovation and integrity
with being sustainable you know um
okay i'm gonna leave it at that very
very quickly uh let's start with jim
i think for us um
we try not to do
you know even if it's a organic cotton
you know even if with the best intention
you don't need another basic key from me
that's what my point is
all right um arabella what about you uh
design innovation and integrity
[Music]
all right and felicia what about you
what are your thoughts on um design
innovation and integrity
yeah our brand is um has always been
inspired by architecture and cities in
texas and because i'm an architect so i
guess that has always been the kind of
the dna of the brand and i think there's
always been a very rich source of
inspiration for us
and sustainability for us it's it's a
value or like like um the other two
brands over here so i think integrity it
really boils down to how well we try to
live out how these values that we have
and implemented in small ways i think
it's great and it's a perfect example of
how you can have design integrity as
well as keep your your ethos and your
values as well and come up with
interesting products all the time okay
one final question for all of you in one
sentence how do you see the fashion
retail landscape evolving between now
and 2030
um okay two sentences and what role was
sustainability play in our landscape um
okay arabella let's start with you very
quickly
right i think it'll be really
interesting to see
how physical versus online addiction uh
internet education and uh
what about you
i think for the physical retail have
they have to have more reason for the
consumer to come in so that it's not
just transactional
there's a lot of talk about experiential
and all that retail for retail and then
there's also the metaverse
oh yeah the
spectrum already so i think a lot would
change over the next
seven years that you gave
wow yeah oh my god seven years yeah
22 now eight years now it's eight years
yeah yeah oh gosh um okay felicia what
about you
i think transparency will be a big thing
so we'll see maybe blockchain playing a
bigger part in fashion right and also
the whole idea of storytelling i think
that would just continue to increase and
how sustainability will not just be
something that you present in statistics
but something that could be experienced
as a shopper being in that space
yeah fantastic thank you very much and
on that note um i'd like to thank all
three of you as uh for joining us today
jin lee felicia toe and arabella
tourette um for joining us in this very
interesting conversation we could go on
and on and on because there's so much to
talk about to all of you for joining us
on this
on this panel design
organized by design singapore thank you
design singapore for bringing us all
together if you want to re-watch this
design singapore will be posting this on
their youtube channel you can also
follow their social media platforms to
find out where
they will be reposting uh
this this videos of today's panel
for those of you who are following the
front row uh
in the coming months this entire panel
is also going to be posted on the front
row so thank you very very much for
joining us today and thank you for all
your really wonderful questions i wish
we had time to answer every single one
of them uh my name is daniel boy thank
you for allowing me to moderate today's
panel and i would like to hand you back
to felicia from design singapore thank
you so much daniel jyn felicia toe and
arabella for taking the time to join us
today it's been an absolute pleasure
it's been so great to hear all of your
insights and to our attendees as well
thank you for being here with us and we
hope that you learned something valuable
too so for those of you who are joining
us from singapore do drop by the
national design center to visit the
waste refinery exhibition to learn more
about how design can tackle one of the
biggest sustainability challenges of our
time waste you'll also be able to find
petite please garments on display
alongside other innovative products in
fashion and beyond at the same time
you'll also be able to visit the good
design research showcase to explore how
designers are addressing challenges of
the future to ultimately create a better
world by design
so last but not least please before you
go we would really appreciate it if you
could do a quick online survey to share
your feedback with us by scanning the qr
code that you see on the left and if
you'd like to find out more about the
programs at the national design center
do scan the qr code that you see on the
right so this is where we will leave you
now thank you once again for joining us
today and we definitely hope to see you
at our future events take care everyone
and goodbye